the Minneapolis Police Chief is out
after one of her officers shot and
killed an unarmed woman it was one week
ago that officer Muhammad nor shot
Justine de Mond on Friday chief janae
harto resigned but as Jamie yuccas
reports the pressures now squarely on
the mayor of Minneapolis the deputy
chief and chief of staff protesters
shouted at Minneapolis mayor Betsy
Hodges and called for her to step down
as they took over the podium at a news
conference to discuss the resignation of
police chief Janee harteau Hodges
returned later to tell reporters she
would not be stepping down
I share people's frustration about the
pace of change in policing and in
building community trust chief harteau
resigned Friday six days after the fatal
shooting of Justine Damon the 40 year
old Australian called 911 to report a
disturbance outside her home but less
than a half-hour later
Damon was dead officer Muhammad nor
sitting in the passenger seat of the
police cruiser fired his gun past his
partner in the driver's seat
killing Damon Justine didn't have to die
on Thursday harto sought to distance the
department from NORs actions
I believe the action is in question go
against who we are as a department how
we train and the expectations we have
for our officers that wasn't enough for
some city leaders including their Hodges
who asked for our toes resignation but
the fact that neither of the officers
responding to Damon's 9-1-1 call had
their body cameras on has raised even
more questions about the department
through this incident we learned what
some of us already knew is that that
body camera policy was screwed to get
from the get-go harto the first woman to
lead the Minneapolis PD and come under
sharp criticism before the 2015 shooting
of Jamar Clark an unarmed black man
during an encounter with police led to
weeks of protests the two officers in
that case
were not charged officer nor is
currently being investigated by the
state for CBS this morning Saturday
Jamie yuccas Minneapolis